the race to be the next speaker of the
house is down to these two Jim Jordan is
known for being a fiery attack dog in
his committees I don't want you to
answer my question the American people
want Dr fouchy to answer the question
and being a frequent voice on Fox News
the left is you know their religion is
this climate change Steve scalise while
he spends less time in the spotlight
became a national figure after being
shot practicing for the Congressional
baseball game in 2017 both Republican
and Democrat reached out it really does
show the form side of Congress that very
few people get to see and is popular in
his party for his career and Leadership
building consensus among members here's
how these two charted a course to the
speaker race and how they represent two
different pasts for the future of House
Republicans Jordan actually got his
first vote for speaker back in 2013
Jordan of Ohio it was more of a protest
vote against then Speaker John Boehner
as were the two votes he got again two
years later Jordan Jordan that year the
majority leader lost his election and
Kevin McCarthy moved up from whip to the
number two position and a new face
joined the leadership scalise we're
going to continue to move forward in the
house as a United Team at the same time
Jordan co-founded the anti-establishment
house Freedom caucus made up of more
conservative members of the House angry
Republican priorities were not making it
into negotiations with the Democratic
White House and Senate they ultimately
pushed Boehner to resign that fall well
are they unrealistic about what can be
done in government that's the dun
absolutely they're
unrealistic Jordan's caucus also blocked
McCarthy from moving up electing Paul
Ryan after forcing McCarthy to drop out
I think I shocked some of you huh and
Jordan later challenged McCarthy for the
role of leader he lost so when the
speaker ship opened up again McCarthy
moved up but not without some protest
votes Jordan and scalise moved up to
leader as the majority leader I really
look forward to bringing those bills to
the floor through a committee process
that's open again but while their paths
to the speaker battle have differed
their backgrounds are remarkably similar
they both represent their hometowns and
win reelection easily they both started
their political careers at the same time
and around the same age as state
representatives and eventually Senators
before becoming congressmen also around
the same time politically they're both
very conservative and both supported
Trump's efforts to overturn the 2020
election do you think the election was
stall and it's not just irregulate it's
states that did not follow the laws set
which the Constitution says they're
supposed to follow 80 million Americans
80 million of our fellow citizens
Republicans and Democrats have doubts
about this election although Jordan is
much closer to Trump personally there's
so many weak Republicans and we have
great ones Jim Jordan and some of these
guys they out there fighting the house
guys are fighting January 6 wasn't
Jordan's first brush with controversy in
2018 former former Ohio State University
students from Jordan's time as an
assistant wrestling coach claimed he
knew about sexual abuse by the team
doctor but Jordan has denied this while
they have a lot in common the primary
difference between the two is in their
beliefs of how to utilize their slim
Republican majority in Congress scalise
is pitching himself as the one with the
experience and personal relationships
from his time and Leadership to bring
party members together I've got a long
proven record as somebody who knows how
to unify Republicans to fight on battles
that matter for the families who gave us
this majority although he's currently
battling a blood cancer he says is very
treatable if the doctors didn't sign off
I wouldn't be doing this Jordan however
is pitching himself as the person who
could unite the more far-right members
of the party who were frustrated
Republican priorities are again left out
of negotiations I do think we have to
have someone who can bring our team
together I think I'm best equipped to do
that so House Republicans will have to
decide do they finally give the rebel a
try or stick with the established
successor